from screen juggling studios in the
heart of Los Angeles this is screen
junkies moving by now your host Andy
signor hello everybody welcome to
amazing episode of movie face I'm so
excited that I'm being attacked by the
graphics already no good show this is
going to be a funny one I said I'm no
pressure to my guests but I just I can
tell it's going to because we have three
really talented plenty people here we
have some amazing topics such as if you
had to cast a live-action minions movie
which actor would you cast if you had to
pick a character is from the movies to
be the best Shark Tank judge who would
it be as well as so much more what is
the best movie with the worst depiction
of time travel I'm so happy to do this
let's get right to it introduce who our
panelists are today first up I'm going
all the way in the end our celebrity
guests are you know them from The Daily
Show and Children's Hospital and hot Sun
Time Machine and so many amazing things
mr. Rob Corddry I'm sorry this show is
about arguing yes debating I thought it
was real fights because I learned like I
learned judo for this right that Ally
pull the muscle in my groin learn judo
show that the product as it is called
seven Iron Fist fails in the East Rob
thank you for coming back we had us tree
Nikki's way early on yeah other guess
who I'm going to mr. Howle run it yes
did he hear one oh yeah warm bodies gon
be training yup Rob got into character
Daniel day-lewis style to play a zombie
and involved actual eating of a human
brain but the cast is very well they
tell me later that it was a it was a
calf brain a baby what's that baby
commitment commitment I hate it
Holly to my brain for sure happy to be
here Andy came here to a kick ass to
bubblegum all out of Oklahoma all right
I love that next up he's our current
champ and he needs to flex his comedy
chops and Merle I don't like the show
so it's in a while it has been sort of
watched has been a regular movement
you're in a weird seat I'm not my usual
seat accepted analyst would you be who
did you be to get here everyone Ms Gaddy
loser actually doesn't everybody go sit
you keep it coming up nothing
about movies well I'm happy to announce
Dan we do have a news for you too we are
announcing that you are going to put the
belt back on the line yeah Thursday July
13 4:00 p.m. live on YouTube and plus
and all over you're going to watch it
live and you're putting the belt again
those delays no delay you can watch
everyone has a wife or p.m. Thursday
July 13th you versus Mike Carlson so
yeah you were saying Mike has thought a
lot recently my god the Madge you
haven't fought fair and he's got Lee's
got the funnies got a funny and I know
these guys have the funny so I wanted to
fight you're going to come in funnier
and let me try to come in funny they
don't know pressure because you have
you're feeling like a little flabby your
yeah but I'm excited so this will be a
good show I know I got some good stars
here let's go to our couch so if they
say anything wrong mr. lon Harris will
be fat checking them he has access to
the Internet Rob so he can tell you
you're wrong if you own the Internet yes
mm-hmm actual internet history hitting
right here am i lighted up as it goes
can we just fight like judo sure I got a
molnár I'm J but you're following along
twitter hashtag movie fights live there
I'm sure they're excited already yeah
Rob uses any illegal holds I'm right
there I'll be all over it try it but
it's good alright so hashtag mu fights
live their Twitter he'll be following
along the feed you build a vote there
and let's get to it now Rob again this
is about debate so even if you don't
believe in your fight midway through
don't give up never surrender no no no
no I want to that's what this shows
about the passion and other end right
I'm right good then you're in for this
time let's do it
lovely night that sounds like boom all
right now one of my favorite shows I
watched I've literally seen every single
episode of the show so I know well it's
show called Shark Tank where they have
other experts in the industry there to
sort of hear pitches from anyone in the
world to give the next big idea the next
million-dollar thing but this stuff
coming season they're bringing a lot of
new people so new energy will be into
this tank I think Richard Branson's
coming in bunch of new people are coming
in but we wanted to ask if you could put
in one movie character what movie
character would make the best Shark Tank
judge we're going to sort with you out
who you pick I thought long and hard
about this Andy and there are a few
criteria that you need to be a Shark
Tank judge well there's just one
criteria you have to be rich but also
maybe a businessperson and I also want
to pick someone who could add to that
Shark Tank panel so I'm going with the
man the myth the legend Willy Wonka okay
the most successful candy manufacturer
in the known universe an inventor he
changed the game when it comes to candy
and to be a candy maker to be successful
in the dog-eat-dog world of candy we got
your Mars your your Hershey's etc you
have to be an innovator who innovates
more than Willy Wonka
so he's and he's got his finger on the
pulse he knows what's going on he has to
he's a taste maker because he's
literally giving people things to taste
and Willy Wonka would be the best Shark
Tank
Judge all right Dan who are you picking
I agree with how that you have to have
some acumen you have to have some
business sense but I think you also have
to have the drive and that's why I have
picked Michael Corleone a Al Pacino's
character from the Godfather films and
I'll tell you why he has an entire
family to support and not that they
don't have money but Michael Corleone is
about two things and he's either trying
to legitimize his family or he has
millions of dirty money millions of
dollars in dirty money that he has to
launder and what better way
longer money than one toilet bowl life
at a time he will find the most loosely
structure organisations possible he will
organize them into ways to either funnel
his dirty money through or bring in
legitimate cash to the business and this
guy I mean that the shark this is Shark
Tank you need somebody who's got the
killer edge and Michael Corleone II has
the killer edge
no one can also go up against a guy like
mr. wonderful that Michael Corleone is
unflappable he's going to give you a
deal he's going to face down those other
sharks gonna make for great television
they have so many personalities on that
show Michael Corleone's would be cool
calm and collected he's going to be the
scary shark is gonna be the best shark
alright Rob were you picking um
obviously I chose I decided to choose a
superhero Bruce Wayne yes
Batman's alter ego I think he fits
easily fits all those qualities that Hal
described and and has a 1 I think he's
easily the smartest smartest of the DC
superheroes and and that's something
that neither of you mentioned was was
just pure raw intelligent intelligence
and you know he's studied for years with
Ra's al Ghul I mean it's like that's the
gauntlet man he had to uh I mean Michael
Corleone you know what mo get to that
but um but he's um he's also I think the
the better investor and and and that's
something that neither you guys didn't
mention like this is all of this is a
show about investing his own money the
shark judges do their own money he's got
money to burn and he's and he has
invested it wisely before all right well
I want you guys to fight out but I want
to know what cut what kind of item or
business are they going to be looking
for that we're going but I'm going to
buy at home mm-hmm where are they going
to step up and help me in that regard
and also just start attacking each other
it seems like every other pitch on Shark
Tank is something about wine so they
might wind by the cup or wine club or
something so obviously with the Italian
heritage and with the Corleone's all
oil connections Michael Corleone is
going to be able to give a little bit
insight there well I'll say that Willie
Wonka he invented the wonkavator he
invented the Everlasting Gobstopper have
you seen this river of chocolate oh yeah
everything in that Factory is like an
invention so he knows gadgets he could
work with people on that level if
someone's going to bring him some get
something to improve your home something
to beautify your home something to make
things at home more convenient Wonka
would be like well as the inventor of
the wonkavator I know convenience he
understands not just candy but gadgets
and invention so he can bully and allow
who understands gadgets more than Bruce
Wayne aka
the Batman hee hee I just totally lost
my train of thought but shut up because
here comes anyway yeah yeah that was uh
that was um I sent myself off on a go
ahead
did Bruce Wayne invent them or did
luxury box L or that's what I wanted to
get to him no that's right no he knows
how to delegate you know and he's not
going to be running these businesses
that he invests in he also has to invest
his trust in these people bringing these
various gadgets to him and I would say
that usually those gadgets the ones the
shows that I've seen have been Fitness
based a lot of the most successful ones
the the surfing one and the surf ball I
think is the most successful one shark
tank fitness space first we're gonna say
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Bruce would
definitely be at all three of em would
it be a problem though that Bruce is a
depressed loner no no that's not very TV
mentally no no listen no no no Batman is
a depressed look loner Bruce Wayne has
an alter ego which he has to prove he
has to show the world this crazy wild
side he's like Mark Cuban times a
hundred on that show and all good TV
Michael Corleone he's a criminal
he wouldn't want that spotlight on us oh
no legitimacy this is all about
legitimacy and what better way to go
legitimate than to be on ABC television
anaconda yeah what got family more
legitimacy than that I could have any
willing like I said wait I got to say
about about Michael Corleone for a
second here and how really how good is
he at his job like Fredo is mentally
disabled brother
one could argue yeah I was able to screw
him over you know like like Fredo didn't
get away with it eventually yeah I mean
a Cuba falling for him too that's a
number that's a great damn point also
Willy Wonka is excellent at vetting and
picking the right people look at all
those kids that he had to dispatch dick
Charlie this is what I want to say about
Willy Wonka though because we're talking
about business here and all I've seen
from Willy Wonka is divestiture he's not
interested in running a business that
his whole thing he was giving his entire
business away and as an entrepreneur
walking into the shark tank I myself
would want assurances from the shark
that I am pitching to that they would
not give this company that I afford my
lifeblood into to a child three months
down the line who has no business
experience a very long history again he
has everything he's the man who has
everything he gave it all away yeah he
has nothing yes I can only got one sweet
job on Shark Tank making making a making
sag scale what we listen once you once
you climb Everest there's nothing left
to climb but it's real way actually
climbed Everest actually won but here's
the thing about Bruce Wayne that I worry
about because again this is about who's
going to be the best Shark Tank judge
and and television is all about
dependability and how many Batman movies
have we seen where it's a banquet or
Bruce Wayne's supposed to make a speech
or something and it pans over and
there's an empty chair with like the mr.
Wayne placard and it's no one is there
and I feel like if the Joker's up to
some shenanigans
well guess what Shark Tank is shooting
and you have an empty chair you have a
mortgage and an empty Bruce Bruce Wayne
is not going to be there shocked if you
start like six episodes on a day
gonna make it her attacks console
titties and guess what
yes your guys are not good businessmen
and here's why they both inherited their
fortunes Willy Wonka built his company
from the ground up so he's the best
businessman also he's going to add
unpredictability and fun remember that
moment where they became stuck in the
ground you thought it was going to fall
down he does a little spliff get ready
for those kind of shenanigans on shark
night well you know what other kind of
shenanigans you should get ready for if
you can invested with Willy Wonka he's
going to push you into the chocolate
River I see a ground I'm sorry I don't
want that murder to hold this with
children like I know assurance brave
also has people to get on the show I
think they'd be like this guy's a
liability I you know he's he murdered
almost murdered and I don't know what
happened a Violet Beauregarde after
after the camera started rolling you
know I mean she wish she was as she was
turned into a fruit yeah blueberry yeah
yeah she's fine she came down and died
it seems he seems to me to not be a good
investor he's not type of like
diversified at all he's just candy and
and he's reckless let me ask you he's
recommend buddy want those golden
tickets um everybody wanted the golden
ticket oh you take a page from
McDonald's my book that's how he just
didn't but nah Polly McDonald's has been
doing it for years looks like a good
thing I get my cup I tear off the
monopoly say I'm like garbage golden
ticket he did it right he won up to
McDonald's but I feel like Bruce Wayne
also is only interested in products that
were late directly somehow to him being
Batman I see that I'm making a gaffe
telander actually I mean he's not gonna
he's not gonna invest in I agree with
very narrow focus is like and they bring
the guy who critically in certain apps
and that's it it's very not interesting
to watch as a shark because if
somebody's pitching you know the fitness
board you know that the Chris guy is not
crazy because things only just didn't
like if it has an app I told the Gloria
she's only the claimant I'm going
tactically yeah I would argue that brute
everything relates to Batman you know I
get anything I like a I don't know I
don't know I don't watch the stupid show
we never liked it I just kind of think
of the as-seen-on-tv aisle in my
drugstore and like all that step for
lights - he's resourceful like what a
squatty potty who could sell that the
best but that's one thing
what's Michael Corleone's business what
are they going to find he do Michael
calling it may have took a meager family
me that you know Don Corleone a rest his
soul did did a great job running a small
family business what Michael Corleone he
did over less than a decade was to take
his family's illegitimate olive oil
mafia business and turned it into a
multi-million dollar casino and I mean
he diversified through so many different
stocks and bonds like he turned it into
an empire
I am the murderer no yes gods like you
it was a legitimate legitimate Empire
know they double back their heads they
plan to pull it back in for our final
closing yeah I am now the creator of the
squatty potty if you don't know squatty
potty it's a stool that goes in front of
the toilets still pretty cool properly
release it real even more a natural
start a fan you know our fun relation
but there's quite potty with a
successful purchase on Shark Tank so now
I am walking into the tank you are each
your judges tell me why I should sign
with you how as Willy Wonka what would
you what would you do
the squatty potty is a step in the right
direction step up on the squatty potty
it's good for your body and then I and
your poops going to go poop right into
the toilet and and I'm going to reach in
and grab it no that's just chocolate
that's a Wonka bar
even if Lanka bars you're going to need
the squatty potty see he would sell it
there's a food and squatty potty
connection okay that's very natural oh
and it's going to have the most fun
squatty potty already rhymes Willy Wonka
loves rhyming Candy's very binding
dad your turn your build up here I was a
as
Corre Leone I would look at an investor
just straight in the eye it would
cyclists and I'm going to take off the
business hat right here I'm going to
speak to you as Michael Corleone's I
know how important it is for a bathroom
to have all the necessary implements
that you need I know how important it is
for a bathroom to be well stocked and
for it to be prepared for when you go
inside that bathroom to make sure that
you come out with more than your dick in
your hands as my brother said that's
right I'm in the bathroom space already
and that's why I'm going to know how to
sell this wedding part of destroying
your whole argument like trying to
picture of Michael Corleone say anything
like that is just alright again I would
definitely get a Bruce Wayne to it
because Michael Corleone II like
personal also big point like it's not
good TV he's just like I'd like to
invest you know he's he's just he's a
anyway how about persuade and selling
out would you Hallie we investments Russ
Wayne would say you're telling me that
this thing will shave about 10 minutes
off my daily poop and he's doing the
calculations in his head of what he can
do with that 10 minutes you know sold
sold a hundred thousand dollars oh wow
no one else offer me money alright can
you mention there one as I take all
those arguments I think an ad there from
the power comes where Speer we don't
really have a lot of evidence that Willy
Wonka's the world's most successful
candy maker is held by definitely he has
the most delicious candy we don't know
he's actually the best selling candy
maker many people online pointed out
that took issue with the idea that
Michael Corleone appearing on TV would
bring more legitimacy they say unless
you already made the business is
legitimate it just brings more scrutiny
to these criminal enterprises also we
don't have any good indication that
Bruce Wayne has climbed Everest
specifically he quietly has an unnamed
Asian mountain in Batman Begins that was
actually filmed in Iceland however not
in Asia son of a other suggestion
a Twitter liked a lot Lex Luthor and
Morgan Joe from Matt Matt Gordon the
DECA Gordon Gekko a very really Jess
chin and Tony Stark came up a lot also
jackson-lee suggest Donald Trump from
home alone to interesting man a
different memory for sure why I would
never be on a reality show
well I got it it came down to Dan and
Rob how I think they did get you on sort
of his the fact that he is really kind
of dangerous and dangerous I'm Michael
croquet oh yeah you know Batman doesn't
like a polio there was also some
disagreement about in the burton version
we do it's implied that the children
survived Willy Wonka's factory you don't
get no one counties the right hand to
bring up this machine while all the like
I didn't I thought that was implied
sorry
anyway I basically came out of Michael
and Bruce Wayne for me
dan you did even though he is a killer
you sold me on all those things pretty
well I love that he's laundering the
money and all those he has a killer edge
against kept mr. wonderful
yeah but then Bruce Wayne you know I was
told store I was torn but then you did
remind me he is that sort of playboy
billionaire attitude he is going to be
interesting on TV where Corleone's
probably very dry and boring it
ultimately came down to the pitch and I
Rob sold me as the owner of squatty
potty I would invest with Bruce Wayne so
I got to give Rob the first point yes
gorgeous portals up on the board a win
all right round two
sign out of our gap who's starting a
wonderful time travel movie we want to
ask we don't wanna go best time travel
movie here because we all agree it's
back to the future mm-hm
maybe Terminator and we could also
probably argue that there really has
never been a terrible time travel movie
yeah sure you know I never ever but we
thought why not try this one what is the
best time travel movie with the least
realistic depiction of time travel give
me the best movie with the silliest most
ridiculous time travel elements that we
still love anyway and Daniel
myself I chose the favorite of mine
still a favorite of mine almost 30 years
old right now Bill & Ted's Excellent
Adventure I think it is still hilarious
it is somehow not really even though
it's made in the late 80s a lot of the
movies from that decade have not aged as
well I think this is aged well I think
it's still funny I love the idea of like
I legitimately as a kid learned some
historic things from this movie about
that good I'm just saying I don't have
five year old this is my first exposure
to Socrates and Billy the Kid different
eras it still has some jokes I think
that work the whole thing about that we
learned there's so many things like Joan
of Arc and Socratic method like this
movies a lot more clever and funny that
people give her credit for I think it
still holds up however its depiction of
time travel even in the loosely defined
realities and rules of time-travel
movies is completely ridiculous there
are circuits of time that you use in a
phone book you look updates in a phone
book but you don't type in the date you
have to type in like there's a prefix
code that goes like if you want to go to
tomorrow you have to dial 2 but you have
to dial 1 and this is it's even among
time-travel movies and this is dude this
is a genre that's had people you know
hit by lightning and you go back in time
it makes no sense whatsoever it's
there's a what no we will go further
into it but as far and if ur n chew
between best movie and least realistic
depiction of time-travel I think that
villain Ted's Excellent Adventure takes
it easily Rob what do you pick I picked
on the butterfly effect one through how
many ever butterfly effects they've
blessed us with and because what is it
he is he travels through time by reading
I think it's basically the concept I can
write I'm not I'm not even sure about
that like it's nothing they do that none
listen I've been in a room I've been in
a room before a writers room you know
for three hours trying to write a time
travel movie trying to figure out what
the device is going to be and we
realized that everybody it's written the
time travel movie has been here before
and has done this and if you were to
actually come up with the perfect one
you'd invent time travel so do you like
the movie look it's got a K in it you
know I can't help but like it for that
reason and I'm just a sucker for
time-travel movies in general I they
always are because of hot oh no no
always from from way back when you know
I even cried at the end of the lake
house which is a terrible terrible movie
so I'm a sucker for it but I it didn't
leave a mark
like I can I can't tell you what the
plot of it was and I'd be dead if I was
going to wash it for this I wanted to
butterfly effect I get it you know you
get the general idea he reads them goes
back in Turkey back it back alright how
what movie are you picking well the
question was best unrealistic so I had
to go with a movie that is one of the
best one of my one of the best comedies
of the past 10 years with a character
who really inspired me lou dorchen um it
just like so full of a flawed a flawed
man in that film but so full of pathos
where you got it and but the movies Hot
Tub Time Machine because I don't know
how fat damn Hot Tub Time Machine work
they spilled did this drink called
chernobly into the tub and then it works
by magic that that's unrealistic okay I
don't get it
Byron but yeah but it's one of the it's
a great comedy I you go along for the
ride it's I think one of the beautiful
things about that movie is that it is
this the most inane collision of things
it's a hot tub and it's a time machine
and there you're there's no way to not
like that movie and it's so funny but
there's no from what I remember there's
no explanation as to how the time travel
works alright find out if only we had an
expert yeah
I may know a little bit about that how
that works now see how you could make an
argument one could make an intellectual
argument about the Nitro try mininum
that is in the chernobly be a device
that once spilled on to the hot tub it
it triggers a reaction that causes a
time machine
what is micro time minion extra try many
a man it's technobabble technobabble is
unassailable
it's a device used and it's like lamp
shading it's everything and you can't
write movies without technobabble but
however I will defend hot tub as being
like I think if you watch it
Chevy Chase explains Chevy Chase's
character the Time Lord or whatever
explains that it's really not about the
nitro minium or the hot tub it's about
these friends getting together after
years and years and years in the same
hotel room with the same hot tub and
they all have problems with their lives
and they go have to go back in time to
fix these problems and like any really
good movie Groundhog Day it's a they
have to learn a lesson they have to
evolve as humans before they can go back
to the present with their lives having
been changed for the better
now when you say it's magic yeah I will
totally agree with you on the magic and
that's not a bad time travel device I
would say it's even the best Groundhog
Day grandma's day is probably one of the
best movies ever written let alone time
travel if you want to call it that but
that's just pure magic as well see I
would agree I think that I think the X
Factor is what Hot Tub Time Machine has
going forward as far as time travel is I
agree like there is an X Factor there
the unknowable the the the technobabble
there could be something there that
caused this time travel we don't know we
don't know what this thing is it's
invented Bill and Ted is positing that
travel to
time is possible via a capsule that
travels literally through a series of
interconnected tube it's how they used
to describe the internet it's a series
of tubes through a series of tubes
through a phonebook that like what's the
phone number for like October 17th 1912
line is every number every date has a
number but inside that date there's a
different number corresponding to the
time of day you can go back in time but
when you come back you can't come back
to where you came from you can only come
back to the same time damn you're going
to be in the past you're shooting
yourself in the foot with your own
argument because it no no it doesn't
most realistic no I really came back yes
no I'm going to tell you why it was it
came out they traveled back from the
Year 26 something and then they go booth
yes in a phone booth yes because it was
a repurposed phone booth so it could
blend into society dan if you had some
big like monolith or something from 2001
like that that would be ridiculous and
they are t-cells all of the hotels you
said all of the details you said just
laid out the most detailed plausible any
about a very detailed logs behind route
yeah you have to punch it into the
curriculum earlier and it would have
been sillier if it was actual dates you
punched in it's just it's a time machine
in disguise okay I was like look you
want to put a book on a telephone yeah
we have a chemical in back here that's
realistic some kind of a chemical
reaction with an unknown chemical that
somehow cause otherwise everything over
here we had Clifford B Johnson this
guy's a physicist from USC I went back
and looked at our videos we are talking
about excellent Days of Future past and
he was talking about time travel today
and he and how was asking about this
would you pass and he said isn't it
interesting if you view the fact that
Wolverine was only traveling through
time in his head because if you take the
possibility of traveling through time
but it's only in your head then all all
instances of scientific impossibility
fall away and it actually becomes
somewhat plausible because it's
something that's only know
to one person well I would then say that
you have a chemical reaction here you
have a possible physical brain reaction
here and here you have invisible
circuits and a phone booth and a phone
book that you call a number and can
somehow end up I play Holi in a billion
I got to say I got to say like any any
time travel device that was made in the
future
mm-hmm is unassailable yeah because it
was made in the future we don't
understand their technology well right
after you Ashton - yeah we're best time
to have a movie with least realistic
depiction of time travel and analyze our
time machine butterfly effect it's not a
good news no it's really I'm not arguing
that point it's really cool that I know
my argument Hot Tub Time Machine is if I
I love that movie its new and when I
fail I feel like I feel like it has the
book is yet to be written on Hot Tub
Time Machine legacy Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure thirty years later
we did our honest trailer poll which a
viewer request it was one of the top
five most requested movies like people
still loves it a great movie thirty
years later it is a great movie so I
feel like looking at this question
best movie least realistic I think this
one hits both of those that are amusing
as your final thoughts Rob final
thoughts I don't think the quality of
the movie enters into the argument at
all it so it's literally boiled down to
the device in which by which they travel
and and to it like I said from that is
with the time-travel device is coming
from the future is unassailable what
about a hot tub hot tub time machine I
argued is a really good really good
depiction of realistic movie time-travel
because because of the night rotation
it's magic but but it's also just Chevy
Chase says like you know you didn't need
it in the first place basically or
something like that
I don't know I haven't seen the movie
heard it's good but the butterfly effect
haven't heard you guys like argue
against that too much he's just reading
it is terrible he's reading
so how final well Robbie said we
shouldn't talk about the quality of the
movie it
question.what best time travel movie so
I feel like that disqualifies the
butterfly effect also we think Dan made
a great point about Wolverine traveling
in his mind there were such there was
such a specific detailed mode of time
travel they actually probably spent too
much time with the specifics and as to
what Bill and Ted how they traveled and
in that phone booth it was to blend into
society wasn't a regular phone booth it
was a phone booth designed by the wild
stallion culture of the future Hot Tub
Time Machine hilarious movie great
performances by Robinson Corddry Duke
but nany said Anandi you said oh god I
gotta love the cute you know what I'm
too taken by lou dorchen but yet they
spilled a drink into the tub and they
went back in time ridiculous all right
come on over there in the Internet
so I the explanation of butterfly effect
time travel is actually very realistic
and specific to the bill he can go back
and have in his former self placing his
adult mind in his younger body when he
reads the journals that he wrote as a
teenager so yeah Wow okay it is time
travel reading that is correct you got
the exact term correct nitro true true
mininum your enemy is the ingredient of
exotic money and he would know I would
help build a villain Ted travel forward
to futuristic city and the year is 2688
and it is made clear in the film that it
is not a phone booth it has been
disguised as a probably to fit in to
1988 10 sorry it looks like a phone no
but every month
futuristic city people made it look like
a phone booth so bad never to change you
and Linda never again that's not their
fault
I just I'm just applying the facts
that's it oh my god I got a Twitter also
liked Land of the Lost came up a bunch
Back to the Future came up a lot Days of
Future past time cop Donnie Darko and
Superman all common era
man and have a bowl Eli wine why steep
into the world and reverb and everything
back that's tough for me because yeah
they got you rob just cuz the movie
sucks and you even admitted it and the
question is better situation but you do
have some good arguments back of the
other two but I think I didn't read the
question because I wanted that back in
time it happens thanks everybody
next how you you know you did get some
good points back on Dan's that you know
it is a repurposed time machine just to
look for the times but the Dan did have
some really good stuff back on the fact
that the physical brain and the chemical
reaction are sort of realistic reasons
whereas what the hell's happening in
Bill and Ted oh this one's tough but
they did combat you with some briefs in
fact so it comes down to what's the
better movie then in my mind and I think
Dan sold me no offense to miss to the
stars together film Wow and it's tell me
a little as to why villain Ted might be
holding up or just kind of that longer
which is sort of a disadvantage to hot
tub both very funny films but I got to
give the slight edge to Bill and Ted's
into this you're just caught me a little
bit harder as why that was the better
film somehow that Dan gets the point
there no boobies and Bill okay I just
want to thank you I said that during the
time dammit can we have a delight
attract Jack I'm going to judge the hell
for putting me in that position by the
way we're going to go bet your movie
against you in order one epinoia seth
rogen children i had to go against the
Green Hornet on Twitter and E of the
photos s
the fans agree 46% went for Bill and Ted
34% Hot Tub Time Machine 20% butterfly
hot damn it I wasn't very funny and I
genuinely do love it but I grew up with
on Ted moving around three here we go
this is a fun one
if there was ever a live action minion
reboot what three performers should play
the minions
that's right we're going to take
Despicable Me or the minions we're
putting real actors in there whether
they're mocap do whatever we need to see
these actors in these roles what three
performers would play the best minions
Rob we're coming to you first this time
um obviously I think
it would have to be Benicio del Toro
playing all of the minions he's a very
versatile actor he's also mumbles with
the best of them can't understand a
goddamn word that guy said some of the
time and which is perfect for the
minions he's also very funny and I don't
know I feel like it's it's it's hard
it's hard to argue against him
it's Benicio you can do anything okay
alright we'll come back and hear more
but how who are you picking injured
performers for the minions Jack Black
Shaq and Betty White
there you have it look at that if you
had rhymed the third one with the other
two that would have been I thought about
it long and hard and yeah and I'm like
you know what I'm just going with Betty
White
so Jack Black would would bring a lot of
comedy he would bring pratfalls he would
bring a physicality to this live-action
minions then Shaq he would bring it
would just be a visual tour de force
giant Shaq as a minion and then Betty
White we've never answered the question
we've never addressed the question if we
have it escaped my purview where do
minions
how are they how do they procreate Betty
White is going to be Eames a like the
Queen alien from aliens Betty White is
going to be the Queen minion who gives
birth to minions and there's going to be
in the script
yes in my in my minions live-action
movie a very graphic love scene in a
sack and Betty White alright geez Louise
Dan I'll go to have to wait too much
thought into this anak Alex yeah I've
picked Tony Hale as Kevin he's the tall
minion with glasses I take Will Sasso as
Stuart he's the one that has one eye and
then I picked as Bob who's the short
with glasses I just did Robert De Niro
because let's be honest this is where
we've been heading for the last 10 years
and
and I think that Tony Hale we know we
can do comedy Arrested Development
obviously look at that look at that
sanam yellow he's already minions Will
Sasso he already took one cultural
plague which was vine and did amazing
things with it so maybe he do a great
thing with minions and then I think that
and again DeNiro I mean what is left for
it's like he's challenging himself to do
things that are more and more make
people go like what and I feel like
that's the ultimate thing and I've got
to be honest I'm kind of curious what De
Niro would do as a minion
nobody sound like I died that's what I
want to know I want to know when he
tried to show any boy my ego method
would he just be like I'm a minion you
know like what would he do I want to
know or what he phone it in like half
another movie now I imagine it was a
minion phoning it in I just the only way
that he would be interesting to me at
this point is if he just went all the
way with it
all right guy find out I think what you
did actually was that you you do for the
character Bob you just kind of lock team
or exact Bob Bobby DeNiro I don't know
but I narrow himself just say Bob and
you're talking about him or his
character he'll incident I feel like we
have to like break these down
individually with mine you don't have to
because it's only one guy which seems
like the right way to go first of all
first of all the artists leaves at your
three main minions right
you also get thousands of minions behind
them if you cast three different actors
to play those minions you've got a
you've got a big job ahead of you of all
these these in fake faces and let me ask
you a question Rob though um has the
minions are often delightful I've never
seen Benicio del Toro play any other
speed than menacing how is that going to
fit into minion territory delightful
unusual suspects very menacing alleys
come on he was a goodtime guy he's just
out for a good time I think you're
thinking of a Stephen Baldwin I think
yeah my thought was only usual suspect
space and so what else you got here Jack
Black no get shirt Jack Black I would
say Jack Black would be a
great choice for all the reasons you use
cited as as all of the minions that
would be perfect I'd watch that Shack
great Colin climbing no yeah great
basketball time incredibly and ever see
on the TNT basketball telecast the guy
is hilarious
every deadpan let's get let's just get
to Betty White
oh yes Kitsap anyway on a sale because
no sir
sir this isn't know this is like stunt
casting at it's worse what but many
white is the is the was the was the old
lady that wouldn't go away seven years
ago and I think finally finally after
like it's incessant Betty White
fatiguing banged on the back of your
head with Betty White every time you
turn on the television of them go to the
movies we finally like stepped away we
finally said that's enough it's one joke
it's a one joke thing that's been done
over it over again like the mini is
really funny we get out get out we got
out five years ago while the getting was
good
no more Betty White we need one more
we need one when I ride one left I mean
Boyka she's at death's door but this is
this is not what it's done created by my
mother think about this by the way is
how it's to bring that into just think
about this what is god forbid Betty
White did this movie and then and then
moved on and this was the last thing
Betty White ever did how did depressing
John you had guest you have gone how
depressing would that be if this was
Betty White's lasting getting carried in
the remember in the only Betty White and
Jack Black is playing by Shan that
it describes the actual penetration and
I love pain by the way I would use a
body double for that scene and there
will be actual repressions no has
Calvin's only one word for it
as of now her last thing would be her
reality show where her and a bunch of
other senior citizens pranked cos that
sounds lovely and really horrific way to
remember Betty White a fun old lady
having fun pranking younger pick that
killing let the woman rest for drink can
we just let her retire in peace she's
already she's already on board she
doesn't want it anymore alright what
about Tony Hale well sazon De Niro do
you guys have thoughts on oh gee I don't
even know this is like this is like a
stew made with whatever you have in your
cupboard during a hurricane I was like
what Tony held there is all of course
like separately these guys are all great
you know Tony Hale would be an excellent
minion playing all of the minions so it
will sasso however I I think that was
kind of an easy choice because I think
that was kind of an easy choice because
just like your De Niro because Will
Sasso was in The Three Stooges and
encrusted so I think that's where your
brain was that's where you made that
connection that kind of easy connection
and just gave I think he gave up on this
question no I did not give up on the
doing Tony Hale you were like brilliant
and then kind of like fizzled out
fizzled out I'm trying to give the
minions a shot I'm trying to give the
minions a shot and I'm sorry no child is
going to go see an army of mumbly greasy
Benicio del Toro is marching across
deserts and no child is going to go
through this if we're gonna do this
minions movie and God help us they
probably are I'm trying to give to
something interesting I'm trying to give
you something funny and I'm trying to
give you some you're here and I thought
it'd been really good kind of thing yeah
it's kind of pedestrian but may I know
my yeah mine is the only cast with a
little bit of diversity to play these
minions and the main point
get back in your pocket my friend this
is not the place to play that come out
betting Shack underrated actor okay
just lying now yeah now that align what
your fault our dream dreaming that he
does not have pleased naturally funny we
can't get a Harry Bradshaw yeah I'm
gonna sorrow get JD on and how he longed
to play the other mission were there any
backlash against the del Toro checking
up looking at the camera please
I'd like a club I just don't think del
Toro is gonna fit uh on by trendy GMs of
like a style of it sound like what is he
doing at usual citrus
what's the line give me the rookies
Burger King little keys foot cuts is a
lot funnier Abby come on he's almost
doing a minion in that movie like it's
not hard to imagine that part that was
almost well Jethro they're heading to
movie enough I think Wendy years ago the
key to my answer the key to my answer
Benicio del Toro is a good one you could
plug a lot of different actors in there
but the key to my answer is that he is
playing all of the minions uniformity he
is able to create these separate
characters it's easier on the weirdo in
different minions you just do he's neck
you know my life yes exactly it's going
to cost the production a lot less money
first of all and and I I would cast
Benicio del Toro on everything
once the true as well so ok good to say
welcome as your final talk but one thing
you notice about the minions when you
watch the movie many of them look the
same but they've got these different
personalities so Jack Black would be the
livewire Shaq would be the more stoic
one and Betty White
would be the wise older one who gives
birth to all the minions there is going
to be a very graphic birthing scene
where she gives birth to all of these
minions and they rise out of this later
this after birth or
because the 94 makers both of these
movies sound like something in a
grotesquerie I think though those who
couldn't play one Wolfman I don't think
he's gonna play 8000 minions I'm just
asking her wolf manager that I'm trying
to give this movie a shot I'm trying to
do the best we can to salvage this and
I've got two people I think are funny
and again who amongst us wouldn't be at
the very least morbidly curious to see
what De Niro can do this would be the
greatest or the worst performance of his
life I think that is gonna sell it or
Bullwinkle well I'm not defiling unless
you are we manage any white like I've
stopped being sad at watching Robert De
Niro in some of these movies but I think
that would manage that to advantage they
like really tug at me I turn around turn
around
I heard enough blonde and agad so Betty
White and Shaq actually collaborated on
a PSA in 2011 you can look it up who was
to any time as he's already playing they
have some on-screen chemistry
she is 95 years young man had a yellow
toro one-upping roll I was able to find
his film debut Duke the dog-faced boy in
Big Top few weeks a very lucky in
general well a lot of other interesting
suggestions of Michael Caine Anthony
Hopkins Sean Connery Adam Sandler Robin
I'm having an issue sure Rob Corddry Jon
Stewart and Stephen Colbert with AOL and
Wesley Snipes Woody Harrelson Rosie
Perez and then building off of Rob
suggested just having Jim Carrey play
all up and came up a bunch of sir okay
Wow all right good good weird
suggestions all right look at ya which
wasn't I thought he had it sort of a
going against them as he picked one
person but he sort of did tell me as to
why that might be actually better
because the other two you had some
oddity in that it didn't end up helping
or your ingredients to rhyme that last
one yeah if you drive it and yet I think
what I've got you there at the end and
how sad it would be to see Gennaro
resort to that last thing so Rob you get
the second point hey yes
yeah all right round four in honor of
the house starring Will Ferrell and any
poll are coming out well what an
existing movie franchise deserves an
installment in Las Vegas that's what
we're talking about take any movie
franchise put wherever you want but it
hasn't done yet put its sequel in Vegas
and how we're back to you to start well
I'm going with Planet of the Apes we
have an evil casino owner who has taken
these Apes and has made them an
attraction at his casino people can come
and see like in a big like terrarium in
the middle of the casino these Apes oh
look at the Apes who are smart look at
these Apes who like can talk can you
talk to an ape can you want to take some
pictures with apes they put shock
collars on the Apes and make them behave
and interact with human beings
god damn it Andy Serkis is not going to
stand for that the Apes will not stand
for that they Andy Serkis played the
Shepherd he doesn't know coyotes are
emotionally you know yes actually
Academy Award nominated role he leads an
uprising to take down this casino ape
world they run through the the spa they
destroy the spa they destroy the casino
and the Apes run free and the last we
see they're running through the desert
to freedom got it okay jailbreak let me
come back into explain where that fits
in the current expansion Dan I'm talking
about there the question is what movie
franchise deserves the movie in Vegas
and I think unquestionably the current
franchise that deserves a movie in Las
Vegas is the Transformers franchise
because I think transformers I think of
Michael Bay and Las Vegas has everything
that Michael Bay loves half-naked women
Foam parties a bubble negev they're
branded and
sponsored from bright light
noises so many things that could keep
him videos brighten right like some
noise it's what he brings to the screen
in every movie that he makes so why not
just cut out the little man and make a
Transformers movie in Vegas you can
destroy any number of landmarks so many
reasons for you know bumblebee that
stumble into a pool party or something
and he can put his camera on whom
everyone to find the next Megan Fox I
don't know it's what he does
Vegas Vic can be a transformer all those
lights and stuff turned into
transformers being in Las the only thing
that I would analogize to a Transformers
movie is being in a Las Vegas casino and
it's just constant input and just
constant distraction and noise and sound
and I don't know where to focus and it
makes me slightly nauseous and it's
better if you're drunk so I am saying
the Transformers is the franchise that
deserves a movie in Vegas because it's
essentially the movie version of Las
Vegas anyway why we just stop pretending
Rob where are you going well you know
what I agree with a lot of what Dan said
about about transformers in that it is
the type of movie that would be funny to
watch or fun to watch in Las Vegas but
it also would be very gratuitous set
there but you do need an action a
big-budget action franchise and that's
why I picked Jurassic Park the Jurassic
Park franchise you know it could be even
be called the Jurassic Hotel and Casino
because Jurassic Park has built into it
that it's an attraction already so it
would seem that if in this reality they
have you know they have replicated the
DNA of dinosaurs then the first P I
can't believe they haven't done it
already as a matter of fact the first
people that are going to jump on that as
an attraction is is the is Las Vegas got
it so we have a Las Vegas installment
that I imagine will go run amok oh great
so we have plan B ace transformers
Jurassic Park I Wow go for guys
Planet of the Apes that you literally
just told the story of what just
happened except it's in lots of it yeah
that's a serial line it's the worst
version of what we are you just got to
fly to the experience you realize
franchise talking about war it's all
right it's not all we go to be normal
it's our past in our past Megan is no
more this story is it's not a sequel or
a prequel
it's an in-between are we ready for a
reboot Charlton Heston version no it's
if the cur it's the current one this one
it come to window like in between right
100 in the world following at the end of
the James Franco one so yeah go it's
like um it's like a rogue one yes I get
very much hey a plan emerges when Tory
huh we have we have a very tightly told
story yeah happened he was doing movies
it really got it on there really gone
out of their way to really liked
elephants alright go to hurry all the
noticing weird vacant yeah exactly yeah
John and rise of as if that wasn't
commanding its needs what do you call it
in Haitian we went from dawn to rot rise
to dawn dawn then now is rise to dawn
Ryu and darn so what's the call title in
between rise and Dawn that under the
Apes
well when stays in the plant with us
that's better than anything I got it
alright I got on a picture let's talk
about transformers yeah thoughts against
Rancho oh my god well it like I said
like it there's there's no reason to put
it in Las Vegas if B it would be the
perfect movie to you they can we can
watch Las Vegas get destroyed if there
was a good reason for that for it to be
in Las Vegas
alright like can I guess cut through the
here all three of these are
terrible so which one of the surrenders
me why do I want to see trip another
Transformers of Vegas well why would I
want to ruin the legacy apply the agent
stick of Vegas prison and why would I
want Jurassic Park to go to Vegas I make
attraction what I go on here that says
the easiest sell well I think that this
Patera looked at both of these
franchises even those motivated Jurassic
world I will agree that there's
potential left for a Jurassic world I
hope you just ruined the greatest
retelling a plan is against
so obviously I don't want to see that
one where there's no where there's no
bottom every time you think you found
the bottom for transformers you find
another one and I feel like what do you
have to lose but see that like it's not
a heightening of the Transformers but
type of man deserves to be in Vegas it
doesn't know it deserves much I mean
they have a hard job ahead of them in
the next installment because in this one
if I understand it correctly they're
like that they've always been here with
us even back in like medieval times so
that's like they have a hard time
already trying to heighten that in the
next movie they'll forget all about it
but like this doesn't matter they ain't
robbed a man not a yes they never
forgets we've seen the dinosaurs in the
city thing with the you know jessica
world is kind of like a little mini
vegas and why haven't you seen the vegas
jurassic world like why haven't we seen
that it's pretty far last thoughts to
try himself expect to you evil casino
owner john goodman not even want to use
these primates to feather his own nest
and he doesn't realize what he's asking
for because they exact revenge that i
mean just seeing those these monkeys
these apes running amok in Vegas that's
the most fun that this will be the most
of time linking out of these plan of the
a shamanic movie guys it's a little
spooky I know I mean if it's not the way
in brother asylum or epic movie but it's
a different it's a bit of a different
flavor but you have this guy who's
trying to make them an attraction
alright the only thing I was able to
avoid is an in-between cool it's called
an inter quell there are some examples
300 rise of an empire came up a lot
because that is told it's let set
concurrently to the first film they're
happening sort of simultaneously that's
about the best case I could find for
what how is suggesting to do with the
Apes franchise other suggestions ant-man
Mission Impossible came up the most
Medea
this morn
best arias and Avengers fast enough
yours was never Vegas either I don't
think they didn't owe you a big ole
semantically Dubai so they've done
memorable skyscrapers that I wasn't
raised a Vegas one this one's rough I do
to the right now I want to run that
trilogy yeah you probably looked up
where they were at in the trilogy
currently might have helped you yeah I
know that so then it came counted
Transformers in Jurassic Park and I
don't want to see another transformers
ever again I read as Rob pitched it I
wouldn't mind seeing the dinosaurs evade
it kind of was already what we saw a
little bit even you admitted they could
do their sequel and I think we're all
don't want another transformer sequel so
Wow Rob you're a boy oh god of this game
the exam line poll 50% went with
Jurassic Park and then even 25% 8 25% to
attending today saying about me like
looks-wise well Raj laughs are in the
lead I think it's good to do another
plug here for you because I got here for
your health come on guys I know I want
to tell them because you have a
wonderful movie it's available this show
on Netflix right now Jim early and
really they can go watch right after
this show it's really good yeah I want
to I have to show up right now and let
it off go watch it after for real and
then also don't forget ballers
July 23rd yhps Mac that must be a lot of
fun oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah there's
nothing not fun about doing that show
especially now that we shoot in Los
Angeles I makes a logical apologies to
the viewers and in Miami but there's not
a lot for me in Miami right so you know
so yeah there's really like it's the
perfect job and you get to be with DJ
all the time I get to be with the deed
yeah yeah hanging hanging just working
out you know I do use like chicken and
protein shakes when I watch him after
the even three seasons I know what I'm
just like think of the option someone
just delivers a barrel of chicken and
right
at the weirdest times a good mmm amazing
all right well yes please check out some
related Netflix and ballers and July
23rd on HBO go set your TiVo's and
things all right question number five
with the news of the accountant - we
want you to pitch us another Ben Affleck
movie sequel now can't be one it's
already in development I don't think
there any other sequels in development
are there look Batman yes I from that
yeah so you can I guess you could pick
account two but let's try and be more
creative
what's the another Ben Affleck movie
from the past we want to reprise his
character in Rupp to you Dan
pretty pickin I am picking in this to be
controversial pick but I'm picking Pearl
Harbor to the reason that I have picking
this is that some people say like well
that's very insensitive
so is Pearl Harbor the movie Pearl
Harbor is incredibly insensitive I
really the only way to retro actively
make that better is to take it so over
the top that no one would even regard
the first one as historically accurate
or representative of anything that ever
happened in any way so it's Pearl Harbor
to the search for Hitler you get a Ben
Affleck you can read from a colleague
out of retirement and it's it's a
globe-hopping quest there's treasure
Rama calling race McCauley is his Nathan
s exactly that is the name Rachel
McCauley
he's on a globe-trotting quest there's
there's yet the dial is inaudible code
and I'm not real historical person ring
for Kali
amongst me literally hundreds of
real-life heroes that you could have
honored appropriately in a Pearl Harbor
movie they chose Rafe McCawley of the
fake one and it really it's just to do
legitimize the first one I feel like
most of that flex movies have not been
that great and I feel like the good ones
you don't want sequels to if it's a good
one so Michael Bay coming back oh yeah
no I told you have to deal with chittim
eyes the first factor you got to bring
Bay back so there's gonna I mean you can
a trainer or marshal that's the thing he
has already established now then a
pocketwatch transformer killed Hitler
yes he will be teaming up with the
pocket watch transformers bubble they
use ties the university guy saw
transformers
together and really I think this is the
only way to wipe away what was done in
that first movie which was really again
very and truly I think insensitive so
let's just go back and try to erase the
first one too and take this thing all
the way over the top because app-like
gets a lot of bad press and I think if
you get a good movie don't don't push
your luck by making a sequel all right
Rob what sequel you said Tom I'm still
not on board with a Affleck as Batman
that's still a big hiccup for me I can't
I just can't
can't he takes me out of it every time
he comes on screen so I was thinking
like well what is a movie what is a
franchise that he's been in that I
wouldn't mind getting vitamin-a flecked
and and it would be the Jack Ryan series
yeah you know they're sum of all fears
yeah because you can't go wrong way but
it won't have his dirty fingerprints all
over it either it would just be like
somebody else's right Nick somebody else
is directing it he's just playing the
Jack Ryan character that everybody is
loved for for decades and books and now
in movies and and you know he doesn't
have to do much
he doesn't have to just say is say his
words make them believable and and then
the rest is magic you know title for
this one that well the sum of all fears
divided by two x kind of a yeah / - I /
- could be a romance there - yeah oh
there's gonna be romantic don't worry
about that how what sequel are you
pitching got you in the board here
Armageddon - were Armagh getting the
band back together
[Laughter]
right it's a present-day Ben Affleck and
Liv Tyler have a beautiful family
together
life is good then the phone rings Liv
Tyler picks it up on the other end of
the line hey it's dad
what we thought Bruce Willis died on
that rock no he was blown into outer
space
and picked up by an alien vessel Oh
this alien vessel took him oh sorry he
was sorry he said he was going on yeah
he said okay so he returns to earth and
he says he was picked up by an alien
vessel turned out it was just a piece of
his DNA that the aliens found and they
made a Bruce Willis and sent him back to
earth with that story to lay the
groundwork for them to send a rock to
destroy earth again so Ben Affleck has
to get Steve Buscemi and the rest of the
gang a CGI Michael Clarke Duncan the
whole group okay the whole group I
thought for a number to be the most
offensive part at all yeah right just
out did it the whole group is back
together to stop Bruce Willis and his
alien compadres from destroying the
earth wait sorry I don't know why I'm
asking for more clarity but we're all
right we're armored getting the band
back no matter what we did rusev came
back to recruit them or that was alien
Bruce Willis hello San lien Bruce Willis
so that's always a no so you just said
they wanted to go again I saw a man find
out yeah but then I realize oh this is
working with the aliens they have to
change they find out and Bruce Willis
he's trying to sabotage a whole team and
then steve buscemi kills them by
stabbing them in the head with a
screwdriver okay all right what do you
think here I love what may I please may
I please may I because I'm offended by
both of these trying to imagine like
putting yourself in an actual like room
at whatever DreamWorks and and you're
getting pitched a movie you're going to
pitch a movie like what movie here would
be the most sellable movie Armageddon
first of all you say Bruce Willis is a
bad guy you're out the door
that's
it's not going to happen Bruce Willis is
not going to play a bad guy maybe he
could in the past not anymore
he's to Bruce Willis II we just won't
buy it
we'll be it to have that ripped away
from us as a viewer not just as the
characters in the movie to to have he
was ripped away from them once before
and he's going to get ripped away again
and as a frond how dare you sir and
Pearl Harbor to the search for Hitler
I feel like this the better joke of the
three is that one for sure like if this
was a real good good I wasn't strict I'm
a pretty pony okay one night with that
company you think one I'd say you
definitely win because like the search
for Hitler first of all Hitler had
nothing to do with Pearl Harbor it was
the Japanese it was though during the
war I was there absolutely we have to
get work no assuring the war these are
the questions you're going to hit in the
pitch room standard yeah no I'll history
were in the picture no and no this is
during the war yes we did the Pearl
Harbor part that was the early part this
is the European front this is a sequel
Michael Baigent like again heroic Ivor's
or you're not here in front yet I
indicated by Michael Bay's making this
movie so none of it matters as he just
put bumblebee back in world wasn't it
Tommy called inglorious battery hung
Nazi banners home there's a house for
this latest Transformers movie think he
cares about history testing it does not
this is again do legitimizing everything
that has come before Armageddon too
since it is a Michael Bay movie like I
feel like that ending of Armageddon was
one of the very few times that he was
able to ring actual human emotions out
of any actor much less Bruce Willis and
why we wouldn't go back and undo that
amazing like that was a genuinely
heartfelt and answer that movie right
where he's on the screen saying goodbye
to Liv Tyler you're putting out half a
Michael Bay to ring more blood from that
stone no I'm just saying you're undoing
one of the legitimately good pieces of
film that he's done which is the ending
Farmageddon and those characters I don't
want to be CGI Michael Clarke Duncan
yeah my god I mean maybe maybe like his
son like think it is Todd Lee just goes
how to kick ass - Michael remarked
Duncan you know Freddy Clarke Duncan or
whatever but but that's just like every
part of that movie is Ted I would think
like Armageddon would be a good answer
if it were just like simple like hey
there's a but there's locusts around the
seas are boiling and they're turning the
blood and and Bruce and then you see
numbers a Ben Affleck in a coffee shop
turn around and he's like what did you
say it's happening again you know that
all by I guess for the purposes of this
discussion but like what happened to
Chris Pine though is we already have
another jock Ryan
it was a shadow yeah shadow work I don't
know if people want to see Jack Ryan
that's my big thing with yours is I'm
not sure even asked like we get to like
a little Jack Ryan I think risk I might
make how dare you sir handle a cake of
Jack Ryan it's like I don't care that
much
we need a flick in this we don't want
Chris Pine to do any Chris Pine is off
doing important things that we enjoy
seeing him in how Smith has agreed to do
a new song for this I'll look at a
couple of course they have open your
eyes yeah final thought there how
quickly the aliens got Bruce Willis's
DNA and then this rogue agent to earth
to try to lay the groundwork and stop
this crew they stopped Bruce Willis at
the last minute and they save the day
man it's it's going to be here as
amazing as okay Dan Papa I mean I don't
know if any of these are particularly
good ideas I think tonight at least
righting a wrong that was done with the
original Pearl Harbor or trying to and
retro actively making it more ridiculous
I hope so other than that I just think
that's kind of another Jack Ryan movies
we didn't care about the last Jack Riley
became
even if a flex back I still don't think
I'm going to care about it and I really
don't want to I mean Armageddon again
Michael Bay that's one of the good ones
and I don't want to see that wiped off
the board getting it right you want to
make money I always like Megan but you
want to make money sure Jack Ryan it's a
short thing in the studio's we like to
we like to everyone so I'll just release
a safe movie we know we're going to we
know we're going to make our money back
on this one yeah that's why you played
this hand right again after some of all
fears
thank you so much money that's right and
and and just Bruce Willis as a bad guy
is just like that that's my best my
biggest hiccup out of all that one
career turn and and I think you're
doubling down on the the the offense of
Pearl Harbor by making it the search for
a hit there anything Michael Bay loves
it's doubling down on being offensive
and that's what this movie is he's a
wonderful storyteller all right one uh
Wow okay nobody on Twitter wants to see
CGI Michael Clarke Duncan not one
suggestion gone over words more people
wanted to see Betty White give birth
Dominion shadow recruit a sixty million
dollar budget only made fifty million
domestic or worldwide gross of one
hundred and thirty five point five
million interestingly Pearl Harbor was
the only film in history to receive both
an Oscar and a Razzie nomination for
worst picture but that was just until
last year when Suicide Squad did it
again other other movies that were
suggested phantoms to people want to see
Dazed and Confused - gone girl - the
number one selection from Twitter was
found to a lot of people in town oh I
thought I was one year old to like still
gone hahaha backers are going going and
gone oh maybe because yeah cheers where
I'm Tubbs I mean come on TJ might you
might have wanted to go so weird
I mean god I was
yeah a lot of people online were saying
Armageddon to really work for that
you're paranoid not honey
but then Dan almost went funnier but I
don't want to see dance either
and yeah you're right I don't want to
undo the one emotional acting moment
Michael Bay was able to make so did come
down to Pearl Harbor to and and sum of
all fears / to rob was different than
use the short thing that it's going to
make money no it's not the short thing
heading into them you walk through you
said that that said uh yeah you did
think sleek and your last thoughts give
me the point that you are doubling down
on the atrocities of what Pearl Harbor
did so just for that alone I got to give
Rob the next point guys we're gonna make
a lot of money on holiday Wow really
mainly we're going to make a middling
amount of money on this that means well
yes I don't need a tiebreaker how many
sorry no you're not in this now you're
not a judge this all right rob me it's
the end against Dan with 1 points here
in buy one you have a big come on
stepheson you got to catch up here in
the speed round my worst performance
unbelief I had always I was robbed
they're always like I'm going to throw
at the end and then look at I'm eating
oh man even giant with you so drawn
right now grown alright well you don't
even know how this works this will be
done for a speed round we have 5 extra
quick questions you'll have to answer
quickly I'm going to answer the question
read the question you'll each have to
answer quickly at the same time if you
both say the same answer it's whoever
said at first so in advance since you
have to say it quickly then you let me
take a moment we'll set the clocks and
you'll each have 20 seconds each to
argue your point this is the speed
version of the show you'll then have ten
second rebuttals I'll explain it again
as we go but the bottom line of all you
need to worry about first is get ready
to yell out your answer as quickly as
you think of a cowboy make sense yeah
yeah alright speed round music let's do
this
whoo in honor of ballers which premieres
again season 2 for write three season
it's a new season 7 July 23rd oh yeah
yeah season 3 right it's getting all
prep started they're going to make sure
prime minister go check about HBO
student 3 7 on July 23rd in honor of
fallers what movie Clark what movie
character would you hire to be
your agent Thomas cruising the color
money not color money in a Tom Cruise
Aneta movie where he plays an agent
cameo name oh really yeah that and
thinking he's like am I gonna take that
um I can't think of something better
gee Pines would be Ricky Roma from
Glengarry Glen Ross Perot's okay Suzanne
got Ricky Roma oh wow
Rob can you think of a the Tom Cruise
character now look at I can do you think
of any movie character that'd be good
any movie character at all was it Rob
poo Ricky Roma I'm a trickier that's a
good one I answered roma doesn't have to
be an actual sports person right right
right right for my agent and it would be
the perfect choice would be for
feel like I just gave you were thinking
of Jerry Maguire is what you were
looking for was a name of the movie
that's the name of the movie yes alright
Ricky Roma vs Thor Dan your first Al
Pacino's character gorilla and go Gary
goes Ross it's about guys who can't sell
anything they're all terrible sales or
they have there's still a craft its own
the worst things and no one can sell
anything except for Ricky Roma even when
he has nothing to sell he will make that
sale he will make you rich he will make
himself rich and that's what you wanted
the sports station you want a guy that's
going to do anything to make that sale
to make the best deal that you can get
you don't want some guy who's going to
sit back okay you'll 22nd times speaking
I don't need the 20 seconds I only need
about five use the time as you will time
will begin when you begin speaking Thor
is a God done it done
all right all right ballsy moment there
Dan you have 10 second rebuttal I think
an important thing in an agent is being
able to reach that agent and I don't
want to try to call them and find out
he's in another dimension or
Guarnere sliding the whole Ricky Roma's
got his cellphone it's got that big
brick phone and he's ready for your call
24 hours a day now you have 10 seconds
when you begin spending Ricky Roma was
only having a hot streak that's
mentioned in the movie that was the
whole point is that everybody has their
hot streaks when he loses that hot
streak he's just a loser like the rest
of them Thor is a God all right just
come back there at the end and help a
little bit how based on those arguments
what do you think you know what Dan made
a good point until I really thought
about it
agents can be tough to get on the phone
sometimes that's part of the bid that
part of the deal man my old manager that
her son of a wouldn't return my
call so just for that reason I gotta go
with the ballsy choice of Thor he did go
bald you there lond
did the ballsy work for you or not work
there was one thing I really wanted to
hear from Rob which is why being a god
would make you a better agent I don't
think we quite threaded that needle we
heard he is a god but I want to know
what what godly about being an agent why
would God help so I think Ricky Roma
Thanks
yeah but then he did give me the point
of the hot streak he did he didn't just
stay there he did give me a reason why
was Ricky might not actually be there oh
it's tough but yeah I think there was a
pretty good salesman would you see yeah
he's a good idea I got a little bit
extra and it was if you're right if he
had just give me one more little line I
think I would have given the baldy
choice that I am today I get it you get
another point there we go so you got the
first point so we're for two all right
I'm sorry the first master all right
here we go
what is the best movie with the word
baby in the title any movie put the word
baby and the title
baby driver bringing up baby ah there we
go
too good alright Daniel first when time
begins when you begin speaking I think
baby driver shows the director and I'd
be right working today at the height of
his power as how would say I think that
it is a master class of what you can do
with cinema which you can do with sound
what you can do with editing what you
can do with humor what you can do with
so many different elements of film all
combined into one movie it's borderline
musical experimental crime drama I don't
think there's anything quite like it out
there or one that I've seen at any other
time bringing a baby is a good movie but
it's alright class in this region
Brad it's a classic bringing up baby as
a classic they didn't even need color
for this movie so damn good
they were like now we're not even gonna
bother they could have done it they
could have met colored it now doesn't
donate it we just got a great story we
got a great story but baby driver hasn't
proven itself yet in the long run in the
long term
alright there's a time 10 seconds damn
bring up baby is a good movie but I
think it's a good movie that fits into a
genre with other similar movies I think
it's a good as part of a pack of other
movies I think the baby driver stands
alone it's singular it is unique it's
not like any other movie out there
that's what makes it stand out for me
over bringing up baby
alright ten seconds he robbed us and
wisely well we don't know that because
uh because baby driver hasn't stood the
test of time yet and the test of time is
what proves a good movie what makes a
movie good all right lon based on those
arguments I mean I we heard more from
Dan yeah Rob made a strong statements
out I think that the test of time
argument was effective but I think I
just I heard a lot more from Dan and
having not even sleeping drivers who can
say more words sometimes just more
our arguments that where they were
contained in more words a little more
points out how though what do you think
oh man so tough I mean well Dan made a
really compelling argument yeah I mean
bring up baby stood the test of time but
yet Dan just had all these points yeah
well you said some interesting is like
it for those who don't know bringing up
baby is you even if you just listed some
of the factors and some things about it
it might have helped reaffirm it so so I
got to give Dan a slight edge there so
yeah we're losing that streak you had
that Robbie might be able to anything
she can about here we go here well I
said at the show in honor of this week's
new Jumanji trailer this is a rematch
question from episode 24 what's the best
movie featuring Jack Black school brah
[Music]
he's right it's cool of Rob and I might
just help him get this point I offer up
my minions pitch alright okay I'm going
to say a high-fidelity oh there you go
your LMS whoo how you were about to give
that up yeah I like that
all right here we go to good at films
again best movies - right Besame
featuring Jack like it's not fetch act
like movie better movie there we go dan
you're first putting aside it's like
they don't think any other movie
captured Jack Black's essence the way
that school of rock did I think it is
such a joyful story from Richard
Linklater about just the joy of music
and how kids can express themselves and
about how adults don't always have to be
the ones that get some that adults can
help you be the person that you want to
be and the idea that kids don't have to
conform being this thing to be
themselves I think that kids and adults
could look at it kissing Jack Black
showed well this is when we first met
Jack Black really in high fidelity and
it's one of the strongest performances
because of
of he's a supporting character and he
supports the the leads on their journey
John Cusack's journey and and for that
reason alone I think it shows her
strength and and yet still you get that
taste of Jack Black and again best movie
featuring Jack Black why is yours the
better movie Dan you're up next ten
seconds I think school rocket something
from everybody I think kids can watch
and take something away for the adults
can watch it and take something away
from it's funny it's sweet it's it's
it's heartwarming
I think high fidelity is clever but it's
kind of in that final ten seconds why is
yours the better movie go ahead ten well
high fidelity I think is the better
movie it's it uses music I think better
than most movies I can think of one
seconds Dan that was no you did your
tires and I was like not got nine second
guys Wow bass those arguments well I
think yeah I think Dan sold me on it
with their rebuttal he took in the
rebuttal there yeah Mon yeah again I
think I think I just heard a lot more
good argues for why School of Rock it's
a great movie
- deli really just got that the music is
used really well which I agree and I
love my fidelity but still think I got
to give the slight edge to Dan yeah Rob
you're going against the best here
that's why it's tough but you can do it
well it's hard to go tonight can I vote
too
yes I look for School of Rock it's great
right John I can do that but I'd like
you to give up on that there we go
alright number four why are now time
wait does number one so number four five
more anymore
here we go back the comment that
commander to commemorate the 20th
anniversary what's the best single
element of Batman and Robin what's the
best single element of Batman nipple
Robin artists or severe Schwarzenegger
versus nipples I love it yes now again
most compelling praise of the film here
and your reason will will sell me okay
so praise us why is a lot of nipples and
sorting of the best part of an Rob and
Dan your I know Rob your first time
because you said nipples I heard you
Fergus oh boy what a bold choice for a
Batman costume it can't be in the in the
style of the original show and who I
couldn't take you can't take your eyes
off those nipples once they come on
screen I don't care who's the O's on the
on there with him
it's a that movie should be called
nipples and Robin a lot of people laugh
at Batman and Robin I would argue that
of everyone involved that film including
Joel Schumacher Arnold Schwarzenegger
was the only one who knew what movie he
was in and I would also argue that that
is a legitimately great performance as
mr. Frese because he knew exactly the
tone that this movie was going to be I
think he was a step ahead of everybody
else on that thing and he's the only
enjoyable thing he's the only reason to
rewatch that 10 seconds Robbie's and
wisely I I disagree I think Jim Carrey
was the the person who knew one movie
who is going to put wait what he'd gone
past what am i wait what am I supposed
to be doing wives are ultimately you're
not good as nipples oh well because I
mean Arnold Schwarzenegger is played
that role before and it's okay you got a
point in there for at least Dan final 10
seconds I think the nipples were the
downfall of the franchise and I think
that again are a source of a good the
best thing about Batman and Robin when i
rewatch it is to watch all sorts of
the ice puns the delivery he knew
he was doing
and moving high usually way you know in
Judaism all right yeah but Jim Carrey's
and Batman Forever
not whatever man kosher you were close
to his presence it's tough all right how
about based on his arguments you know
I'm going to give it to Dan but nipples
and Robin is the funniest thing I've
heard at all yeah I give nipples erotic
sometimes comedy gets the point for me
yeah I was gonna say let's see London
you could sway me where you going oh I
was leaning definitely towards raba be
like Dan he made up he made us Batman
Forever mistake but Dan just kind of
repeated a lot bit short today you're
sort of knew what he was doing and I
think uma thurman also kind of knows
she's camping it up in that role as well
so I'm going with that nip right which
Robin said but is the point we have to
take it's not you know if a fact is said
it's not not fact we can basics I agree
there's other things happening but man
nipples are you can't you can't not see
them you can't a few image people say
Robin Williams they should call that
movie nipples and Rob
so that gives Rob the point I'm going to
go get Rob gets the point there's still
one last question here if you get this
boys as a tiebreaker so how we do the
rules here yes okay we do it then we
have to have two more all right here we
go ah this is horrible
who would you want I'm going to name two
people just Rob and dance you're
prepared okay
so just you're going to hear one and
yell which one you want them it's not
it's not a broad choice um pay I'm going
to list to who would you want to see
return more Wesley Snipes has blade or
Ron Perlman as hell boy where's this
knife run Portland okay Rob got Wesley
and run for Dan I think I heard Wesley
first you're up 20 seconds whenever
you're ready wait this time to plate why
do you want to see Wesley Snipes return
his bleed more than Ron Perlman is
homeboy well because first of all we run
Perlman never went anywhere I I want to
see Wesley Snipes return in his best
role in in one of the best up until you
know this new Avenger stuff the best
comic book adaptations in history of
movies it was really good scary damn I
feel like Leslie's nice and blade or on
a gradual or maybe not so grudge
decline as the movies went on from what
you hear from Ryan Reynolds that nozzle
of other people most of what you saw
with his stand-in in blade Trinity I
think that Ron Perlman as hell boy was
on an incline I think people wanted to
see more of those he actually got that
character people loved him as that
character when Guillermo del Toro T is
doing a third Hellboy people were very
excited about that
I don't ten seconds for erupt and what
am i doing that before again you're fine
same a same argument why you want to see
to combine what he just said why
Wesley over Ron Perlman yeah I don't
think that's something like that that
will probably happen I mean Ron Perlman
is in the franchise the franchise is not
dead
however the the blade franchise is very
much dead and we ten seconds in I think
if we're going to get one more movie
from either one of these people it's
going to be the one that excited the
fans of the comic the most I think
that's wrong purlins I think it's the
one that's got the biggest appeal and I
just think rusty Snipes is overdoing
blade I don't think he wants to do
anyone all right
law and baseman's arguments tough
actually I felt sort of compelling
arguments of both sides but I think I
think I got to give the edge to Ron
Perlman just because Rob's last sort of
remark like it is basically dead I don't
feel like we're going to see Ron Perlman
his Hellboy any more so I the rebutted
didn't really go ahead which is unfair
because he's not a big of a Nerdist we
are it was we Paul followed yeah sure
David harbors taking over for Hellboy
but I mean they put it on helperman out
I just say whole last rebuttal didn't
have like a really good yeah fair but I
agree I heard a good thing but how are
you standing on I didn't hear anything
from Dan that got me more excited than
Rob saying that like Wesley Snipes has
been gone yeah he was taken from us and
now he's back and to see him take that
role again would I find it delightful
kidnapped well yeah
yeah you could get me more excited but I
think I heard a little bit more just
again from Dan so I got to give the
point to Dan there we'll put this in the
final tiebreaker thing last question and
I think we have a bargain bin yes we do
a bargain or dinner table do let's end
on this bargain minute so what some
happen Rob and look at this TV for the
final point I'm going to throw two DVDs
up there from a fan you have to pick
which one should we buy okay so pick
which of the two movies you're going to
see should we buy let's reveal it to
Louise Norbit
cat in a head all right
what a way to edit nervous and the Hat
so Rob tell us why we should buy and if
you'd like to see would you like to DVD
up there to help you is sure what okay
why not tell us why are we buying Norbit
over cat that's the reason I mean Eddie
Murphy has everyone again and cause I
just want to watch that again to make
sure if what I saw in the past was true
well movies like that would be an
interesting where you watch over the Cat
in the Hat
the cat hat I mean I there's nothing
really interesting that happens and then
here's the thing about Norbit I look at
Norman and I see minus one Oscar in any
man's hand I think it has been
documented that Eddie Murphy had won
that Oscar for two girls and that went
up and it cost him that Oscar anybody
would be an Oscar winner Tom for that
movie i watch the movie makes me angry
cat ahead at least you has a dr. Seuss
story at least you have that foundation
to base on it's a timeless story it's a
children's classic you think that's a
long way
Wow good all right this is good 10
seconds Rob I met her when my kid said
can we watch Cat in the Hat
again and I was like oh god no let's not
watch that again because look at his
face but Mike myspace terrifying because
I'd rather just watch Eddie Murphy
farness different characters
and I hope I said far less respect lose
for Mike Myers by the time Canada hat
rolled around that I did for Eddie
Murphy Eddie Murphy it's just depressing
it doesn't mean laughs it makes me sad
why he was on his way back and you were
coming back did you knit it Wow all
right this is for all the marbles
how based on those arguments ryeowon oh
man you know what Mike Meyers face is a
dream haunting often yeah I think I got
a I think I got to go square nightmares
go huh yeah also I want to see that
performance that stole the Oscar already
interesting oh yeah yeah I Rob really
got me with that argument of like I need
to go back and verify than what I saw
was real that is kind of it Samba with
Rob Kent well he got me there but then
yeah he took me over the edge with the
nightmare fuel yeah so yeah that guy
while I agree with sad to see it Hey
yeah the argument if I want to see what
is so sad what happened Rob gets the
final point and Rob getting lonely yes
oh that was an intense battle sir
through all the way the Enzo is up wow
what an honor sir you really brought it
down mark my bag up for that part not my
bag I told you guys I was going to throw
it if I was winning and I'm going to
yeah we'll only took like five questions
until you like we've built enough of a
lead to get in there oh my god I'm back
from Dan Rob Marjorie what you are such
a pleasure sir I'm so thankful for you
Goodman's a lot of having fun and I want
to make sure everyone our audience goes
and watches a shimmer Lake available man
all right Netflix you're not I like it
yeah great movie for real go see it
click on it right now everyone has
Netflix who watches up you got Netflix
so does there if not borrow your friends
code and their look Oh or borrow your
friend HP okay now we'll go on our jet
owners torrid side okay right here HBO
Go password from someone and watch
baller starting again July 23rd what's
happening to seasons anything that we
can be looking forward to yeah yeah it's
this season's going to be great because
you know there is a loose sort of
ballers formula you know like he gifts
himself into a lot of cheek dive into D
on how do they have like the entourage
the formula there that you try and try
and borrow from ever sings okay no no no
no that that formula burn no and and but
this time it really is like they have
height they've learned how to write this
show and its really heightened in a way
that is very appropriate well I met
earlier I liked entourage early
entourage yeah went to oh yeah early
audio and one was like a documentary
Hollywood yeah I like it but baller
start started and that sort of like oh
it's not rise playing the sports world
which is really fun with you and the
rock I mean come on what a cat I mean
come on come on who can say no time on
it's awesome okay July 23rd on HBO GO
HBO everywhere and shimmer like a
Netflix thank you rob
how rad Nick screen deck shown you're
going to be an America's Got Talent
I am going to be on America's Got Talent
so please follow my character that I am
playing his name is Eric Jennifer you
can follow me at Eric Jennifer on
Twitter or Instagram
and visit my website
Eric Jennifer calm and you can learn
more about the good boy of comedy
Karianna for good now wait we're all of
the JC's changing it away with things
screens and keep the show underneath how
I been there GT not it haha yeah you
know of two weeks from today and Wyoming
is our 13th I will be fighting Mike
Carlton lying on one on and on right I
damn well better be funnier than I was
today yeah but I applaud you for Joe in
there you got right to the end there but
man good work and a July 13th Thursday
all the YouTube Watchers come tune into
screen dogies youtube watch the live
belt battle lot harris thank you for
factoring today i think you'd like to
plug just follow me on twitter at LNS
I'm not on America's Got Talent
playing a character oh yeah coach Ellis
and I did next season maybe yeah yeah
the game master can go on gotta go
awesome and now you can follow me
everywhere at any signal all the social
medias thank you so much guys for
watching and thank you to rob thank you
so much for coming by what employer
music finally someone legit comes in
here and a very very fun thanks and take
you all home for watching we will see
you next week have a great weekend bye
bye bye